Dann kannst du die Beine
auch mal nach oben nehmen -
zum Himmel.
So ein bisschen ausstrecken,
die Arme dazunehmen
und mal die Fuss- und Handgelenke
rausschütteln.
Die Knie bewegen.
Aus der Hüfte heraus
die Beine, Arme, Ellbogen
und Schultern bewegen.
Mal richtig alles rausschütteln!
Alle Anspannung raus!
Allen Druck raus! Jawohl! Ah!
Kräftig! Ah!
Ah! Und nochmals!
Und alles raus! Ah! Ja!
Wunderbar! Sehr gut!
* Sanfter Gesang *
Ich war im Management von grossen,
internationalen Konzernen tätig.
Ich merkte über die Jahre hinweg:
Der Druck wird einfach zu gross.
Ich arbeite sehr viel und entferne
mich immer mehr von meiner Essenz.
Viel Geld verdienen, immer eine
höhere Rendite haben, mehr Profit -
die klassischen Themen
in der Wirtschaft.
Die Befriedigung
wurde immer weniger.
Am Ende
kumulierte es sich im Körperlichen.
Ich wurde krank.
Dann bekam ich
die klassischen Stresssymptome:
Anspannung, Druck,
Schlafstörungen, Aggressivität.
Ich bekam dann auch
eine schwere Hirnblutung.
Das war für mich ein Zeichen,
dass es so nicht mehr weitergeht.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Sanfter Gesang *
Deine Schultern dürfen noch
ein bisschen mehr zum Boden sinken,
weich werden.
* Sanfter Gesang *
Wie zentral ist es,
an sich zu arbeiten,
sich weiterzuentwickeln,
oder man könnte auch sagen,
sich selber zu optimieren?
Ich glaube,
es ist schon sehr essenziell.
Es ist die Frage:
In welcher Phase meines Lebens
stehe ich?
Habe ich die Ressourcen dazu?
Habe ich die Kraft dazu?
Habe ich die Zeit dazu?
Und was ich oft beobachte:
Ist der Druck gross genug,
um etwas zu ändern?
Es braucht schon auch immer wieder
einen Einfluss von aussen.
Es muss etwas passieren, damit ich
reflektiere: Geht es so weiter?
Möchte ich so weiterleben?
Oder kann ich an mir etwas ändern?
* Sanfte Musik *
Mein Mantra, das ich immer
von meiner Mutter gehört habe ...
Ich liebe meine Mutter,
ihr wisst es ja:
"Oh,
was sollen die Nachbarn denken?"
"Mit deinen zerrissenen Hosen,
deiner komischen Musik
und deinem komischen Auto
mit all den Bierdosen?"
Wie es halt so ist
damals auf dem Dorf:
"Was sollen denn
die Nachbarn denken?"
Aber wenn ich das so absorbiere,
lebe ich nicht mein Leben,
sondern dasjenige meiner Nachbarn.
Ich mache mich über diese Menschen
nicht lustig.
Ihr versteht das.
Wenn die Prägung so stark ist,
ist es schwierig, da rauszukommen.
Also: Ich erkenne diese Prägung,
diesen Glaubenssatz.
Und jetzt übe ich, den anzunehmen.
Ich will halt beliebt sein.
Ich kann nicht Nein sagen.
Oder: Ja, ich bin pedantisch.
Ich bin perfekt.
Und ich muss das alles
zum 13. Mal nachrechnen.
Das ist jetzt so.
Dann übe ich eben, das umzuwandeln.
Möchtest du nach vorne kommen?
Möchtest du dich mal so hinstellen,
wie du dich wohlfühlst?
Ist der Abstand so in Ordnung?
- Es ist okay.
Gut!
Du kannst die Augen mal schliessen.
Und jetzt ganz bewusst
die Füsse wahrnehmen,
ein bisschen Kontakt
mit dem Boden haben.
Die Aufrichtung wahrnehmen.
Die Schultern ausrotieren.
Führe den Hinterkopf
noch ein Stück mehr nach hinten!
Nimm wahr, wie du jetzt dastehst:
geerdet, kraftvoll ...
... ganz stabil, fest.
Und während du so atmest,
bist du ganz bei dir.
Ich lese dir jetzt Sätze vor.
Lass diese einfach auf dich wirken
und schau, was passiert!
"Ich akzeptiere,
was ich nicht ändern kann."
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
"Störungen sind Teil des Jobs."
"Ich bleibe gelassen,
auch wenn ich nicht weiss,
was kommt."
Gut!
Gibt es da einen Satz,
bei dem du eine Resonanz spürst,
einen Satz, der dich anspricht?
Ja.
- Möchtest du ihn sagen?
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Sehr schön!
Sag den Satz nochmals - auf Mundart.
So, wie es für dich stimmig ist.
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Mal tief einatmen!
Und sag den Satz nochmals!
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Sag den Satz lauter!
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Noch lauter!
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Und kräftig! Laut!
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Leg mal deine linke Hand
auf dein Herz
und die rechte auf die linke Hand!
Sag den Satz nochmals!
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Jawohl.
Gut.
Vielen, herzlichen Dank
für die schöne Übung!
Was hast du im Verlauf der Übung
wahrgenommen?
Dass es mir leichter fiel,
den Satz zu sagen,
aber noch nicht ganz so ruhig,
wie ich ihn hätte sagen sollen.
Diesen Satz ...
Wie lautet dein Satz?
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Den wiederholst du jetzt jeden Tag!
Kennst du diese Post-it-Zettel?
Du klebst sie auf
deinen Kühlschrank. Was steht drauf?
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Genau! Dann öffnest du
den Spiegelschrank im Badezimmer.
Dort klebt ein Post-it -
mit welchem Satz?
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Genau! Dann öffnest du die Tür
deines Kleiderschranks.
Es ist 12.15 Uhr. Wir müssen essen.
* Lachen *
"Ich muss nicht alles
kontrollieren."
Die Zeit ist egal.
* Kirchenglocke *
* Sanfter, kirchlicher Gesang *
Und je mehr ich in die Ruhe komme,
je mehr ich eben diese Gedanken
und den Geist zur Ruhe bringe,
desto mehr komme ich bei mir an.
Und gerade in unserer Gesellschaft,
die sehr stark
durch materielle Dinge geprägt ist,
materiellen Wohlstand,
Glücksversprechen im Aussen,
ist es nicht einfach.
Und oft erkenne ich auch,
wenn ich mit meinen Klienten
intensiver zusammenarbeite:
Ich liebe Orte des Rückzugs -
einfache, im Kloster.
Dort blühen sie auf.
* Sanfter, kirchlicher Gesang *
Ich hatte ein Schlüsselerlebnis,
das mich sehr stark prägte:
Ich wurde schwer krank
und lag im Krankenhaus.
Es war nicht klar,
ob ich diese Nacht überleben würde.
Ich verspürte eine ganz tiefe Ruhe
und einen grossen Frieden.
Und das war das erste Mal,
dass ich spürte ...
Ich kann es nicht in Worte fassen -
damals nicht, heute nicht.
Aber ich spürte: Es wird alles gut
oder es ist schon alles gut.
Und das war für mich
eine wichtige Erfahrung,
dass ich vertrauen darf.
Und es war für mich auch
eine wichtige Erfahrung,
dass da etwas ist,
was ich lange, lange gesucht habe,
auch wenn ich es nicht
in Worte fassen kann.
Und das möchte ich
näher kennenlernen und erkunden.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Er atmet laut. *
Kommt meine Arbeit
bei den Leuten an?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich vergleiche es ...
... mit einem kleinen Samen,
der gepflanzt oder gesät wird.
Aus diesem Samen
kommt ein kleines Pflänzchen,
das gegossen und gepflegt
werden muss.
Und irgendwann
kommt da ein Pflänzchen raus,
irgendwann eine kleine Blüte.
So sehe ich auch meine Arbeit.
Am Ende kann ich keinem Menschen
helfen oder ihn retten.
Das ist auch nicht mein Anspruch,
das wäre vermessen.
Was ich Menschen mitgeben kann,
ist eben eine andere Sichtweise.
Ich kann ihnen
meine Erfahrung schildern,
Übungen und Techniken mitgeben
und Sichtweisen aus
asiatischen Wissenslehren zeigen.
Ist der Platz hier okay?
Willst du dich woanders hinlegen?
Wo möchtest du deinen Kopf hinlegen?
Genau! Dann bringe ich dir noch
ein Kopfkissen oder eine Decke.
Hast du einen sensiblen Rücken?
Möchtest du was
unter die Knie nehmen?
Nein, es ist gut so.
- Möchtest du dich zudecken?
Nein.
- Gut.
Dann komme mal ganz bewusst
in deinem Körper an!
Nimm den Körper wahr!
Nimm wahr,
wie dein Körper jetzt schwer wird!
Dein Kiefer ist locker.
Deine Zähne berühren sich nicht.
Was lastet auf dir?
Auf deinem unteren Rücken?
Wie alt warst du da?
14, 15, ja.
Wo stehst du jetzt
in diesem Elternhaus?
In deinem Zimmer?
- Ja.
Was braucht Patty
jetzt in dem Moment,
wo sie in diesem Zimmer steht
und weiss, es ist viel zu viel?
Zu viele Schulaufgaben, Arbeit,
dann für den Vater
noch da sein müssen oder wollen.
Was braucht Patty?
Was braucht sie?
- Leichtigkeit.
Leichtigkeit.
Möchtest du jetzt
als starke, erwachsene Frau
mit der ganzen Kraft, die du hast,
zu Patty gehen
und sie fest in den Arm nehmen?
Möchtest du ihr sagen,
dass du für sie da bist?
Ja, gut! Lass dir Zeit!
Wie reagiert sie?
Gut, schön!
Bitte?
- Sie muss auch weinen.
Sie muss weinen, jawohl.
Darf sie weinen?
Gut.
Bitte?
Ja, genau.
Sie lächelt.
Wunderbar, das ist schön!
Dann lass die Augen
jetzt mal geschlossen
und atme mal ganz bewusst tief durch
die Nase ein - bis in den Bauch.
Kraftvoll!
Reibe deine Hände kräftig!
Noch mehr!
Und jetzt die Wangen,
die Ohren, den Kopf, Hinterkopf.
Kräftig! Alles kräftig reiben!
Und die Schultern!
Richtig ausstreichen!
Den Oberkörper!
Alles weg! Alles weg!
Noch mehr! Weg!
Alle Wut, alle Trauer,
der ganze Schmerz - weg!
Weg!
Trink mal einen Schluck Wasser!
- Ja.
Danke!
Lass dir Zeit!
Wo stehe ich auf meiner Reise?
Eine sehr gute Frage!
Ich ...
Ich sehe mich am Anfang.
Ich glaube,
es ist nie abgeschlossen.
Es ist ein ständiges Lernen
und Erfahren.
Sicherlich auch immer wieder
mit Rückschlägen verbunden,
auch mal mit einem Stillstand.
Aber es entwickelt sich
kontinuierlich etwas.
Man könnte salopp sagen:
Mein Zusammenbruch
war auch mein Glück,
dass sich da eine neue Tür öffnete.
Man könnte sagen:
"Jawohl, mit der Erfahrung,
die ich gesammelt habe -
im Positiven wie im Negativen -,
kann ich einen Schritt weitergehen
und etwas tun,
was anderen Menschen hilft,
sie unterstützt
und ihnen vielleicht
Orientierung bietet."